اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في هذه النافذه للتحليل
العسكري لمجريات حرب اسرائيل على قطاع غزه
وفيها نستضيف المحلل العسكري اللواء فاز
الدويري ونتابع بدايه اخر تطورات المشهد
ميدانيا على الخريطه التفاعليه مع الزمي
سلام خضر خصوصا بعد تصريحات في ها اريتس
وردت تتحدث عن غرق اسرائيل في غزه في رمال
غزه في وحل غزه ولكن السؤال الشمال ما
يحدث في الشمال هل هو مؤشر لهذا الغرق
وكيف قوات ترسل ثم تسحب ثم تتوغل سريعا
بالضبط قد يكون ما يجري في شمال غزه ليلى
هو البلوره الميدانيه لما تحدثت عنه ها
ارتس عن الغوص في قطاع غزه وايضا ما تحدث
به نتنياهو عن ان اسرائيل ستكمل في هذه
الحرب ولكن الجنرال جادي ايزنكوت يقول لقد
فشلنا بهزيمه حركه حماس يتبلور هذا في
الشمال عند اكثر من محور لا تزال
الاشتباكات في التفاح والدرج جاريه على
قدم وساق واشتباكات توصف بانها ضاريه
وعنيفه القوات الاسرائيليه بعد كان ان
كانت قد انسحبت من شمال القطاع واعلنت
انها خففت من وجودها العسكري لا تزال تشن
هجمات مباغته الى عده مناطق في الشمال
تهاجم من المناطق من السياج الحدودي
وتتوغل الى داخل القطاع اليوم ليس فقط
التفاح والدرج هناك اشتباكات امتدت الى
جباليا المخيم وجباليا البلد سجلت
اشتباكات مستمره لعده ساعات بين كتائب
المقاومه وبين قوات الاحتلال ترافق ذلك
ايضا مع استمرار سماع دوي انفجارات واسعه
في التفاح والدرج وفي جنوب مدينه غزه
يعتقد قد انها تفجيرات ينفذها او تنفذها
القوات المتوغلة
للتصدي لهذه القوات المتوغلة
عن المغازي اشتباكات ايضا وايضا دخلت
القوات الاسرائيليه من منطقه الجنوب
الشرقي الى منطقه المخيمات كان هناك
مقاومين تصدوا لهذا التوغل ويقولون انهم
اصابوا على الاقل جنديين اسرائيليين بقنص
بعمليه قنص مباشره اضافه الى هذه ايضا
تتعرض المنطقه لعمليات قصف مستمره صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز كانت قد نقلت عن الجيش
الاسرائيلي انه في مخيم البريج على وجه
التحديد تمكنت وحده يا هالوم الهندسيه قبل
انسحاب قوات الاحتلال يعني قبل يومين من
الانسحاب من مخيم البريش تحديدا تقول انها
عثرت على نفق فيه وان هذا النفق كان من
انفاق القياده ومن انفاق التصنيع العسكري
طبعا العهده على ما نقلته نيويورك تايمز
عن القوات
الاسرائيليه الجنوب ايضا لا يزال منطقه
مشتعله وربما هي المنطقه الاكثر اشتعالا
النقطه الاساسيه ونقطه الاشتباك الاساسيه
هي مدينه خانيونس لا تزال القوات
الاسرائيليه تحاول الوصول الى قلب المدينه
توغلت في بعض الاحياء لكنها لم تصل الى
قلب المدينه اليوم ايضا لليوم الثاني على
التوالي تستعين بالطائرات المقاتله وتنفذ
غارات عند اكثر من نقطه في جنوب القطاع
واللافت مره اخرى ايضا هو قيام قوات
الاحتلال بتفجير مربعات سكنيه في اكثر من
منطقه في جنوب قطاع غزه يقومون بتفخيخ
المباني السكنيه التي تشكل المجمعات
ويقومون ايضا بعمليه نسف متزامنه اي هد
هذه المجمعات السكنيه في وقت واحد واليوم
ايضا سجلت بعض الاشتباكات في المنطقه
المحاذيه للشريط الحدودي و وايضا سجل قصف
في هذه المنطقه هذه ابرز التطورات
الميدانيه ان ربطناها بما بالاراك على
صعيد الخطاب السياسي داخل اسرائيل قد نفهم
ربما لماذا تتنقل هذه الاشتباكات ولماذا
تدخل القوات تتوغل القوات ثم تنسحب ولكن
القراءه الامثل والاكثر عمقا نعود اليك
لمتابعتها ليله شكرا جزيلا لك السلام على
كل هذه المعلومات
اذا في اليوم ال 105 من هذه الحرب اسرائيل
تحتفل باكتشاف فوهه نفق هنا وهناك كما
اشارت سلام
للتو تسحب قوات من هنا ثم تعيدها
وخسائر كبيره تعلن عنها يوما بعد يوم كيف
يفسرها يعني جرت عده احتفالات
للتذكير الاحتفال الاول كان الحديث عن
النفق في منطقه بيت حانون وجاء الرد
المهمه انجزت وصلت متاخره الاحتفال الثاني
كان بالعثور على فرده حذاء السنوار وتحدث
عنها داخل الكنيست احمد
الطيبي الاحتفال الثالث انسحاب الكتيبه 13
منلوا جولاني من الشجاعيه وشاهدناه وهم
يحتفلوا ويرقصوا لانهم خرجوا من مازق ومن
ورطه والان احتفال رابع وسلسله الاحتفالات
السخيفه ستستمر ما دامت الحرب مستمره
واللافت انها تتوازى مع تحليل عسكري في
اريتس كما ذكرنا يقول ان اسرائيل تغرق
يعني الصحف الاسرائيليه ما يكتبه الكتاب
والمحللين العسكريين لا اقول هو عين
الصواب هو اقرب الى الصواب لان عين الصواب
حتى
هارتس وغيرها لا تذكره الرقابه العسكريه
مؤكد ستمنع الان ساعطي صوره من قراءتي لا
اقول انه تجسيد للواقع بصوره 100% لكن بعد
105 يوم من عمليه المتابعه الحثيثه
والتحليل المستمر يوميا لدي قراءه معينه
تفضل لنذهب الى الشمال نعم الان اذا ذهبنا
الى الشمال بصوره كامله لو سمحت بس ل
الخارطه اللي تعطينا الحدود الان تم
انسحاب ثلاثه فرق اين ذهبت
ذهبت اتجاه حال عوز ومعبر ايرز ذهبت الى
الشرق من تله زعتر وبيت حانون داخل الغلاف
والفرقه 36 ارسلت الى المنطقه الوسطى لكن
هناك لوائين موجودات في وادي غزه الى
الشمال من البريج
و نصيرات والفرقه 36 التي سحبت لم تكمل
انسحابها خارج الحدود يتواجد جزء كبير
منها لا يزال الى الشرق من جحر ديك بس
ترفعي لنا الخارطه شوي لو سمحتي الان اذا
نقاط الارتكاز اصبحت تقريبا شبه واضحه في
وادي غزه الفرقه 98 تق 99 تقاتل ولكن لا
يزال هناك بحجم لوائين في وادي غزه الان
في منطقه نحال العوز كفر عزه الى غير ذلك
يوجد هناك تجمع الفرقه 36 الى الجنوب
ويوجد كمان الى الشمال هذه الفرق ه هذه
الفرق هي في حاله اشتباك جزئي اذا ذهبنا
الى المنطقه الوسطى لوائين وهي قوه اضافيه
اضافه الى الفرقه 99 هذه تقوم بعمليه
المشاغل هي
موقعها تسيطر او تتواجد لا اقول تسيطر
تتواجد في منطقه عرضها 3 م بعمق 5 م من
الغرب من جحر الديك الى شارع الرشيد هذه
تقوم بعمليه مشاغله يوميه سواء باتجاه
الجنوب باتجاه بجاه البريج والنصيرات او
باتجاه الشمال باتجاه الزيتون وباتجاه
الشيخ عجلين وتل الهواء ولكن عمليات مطره
ولاحظنا انه ذكر اشتباكات في الشيخ عجلين
ذكر اشتباكات في الزيتون اذا ذهبنا الى
المنطقه الشماليه الاكثر سخونه نجد ان
الوحدات خاصه القريبه في وضعيه الاستعداد
القتالي وتقع الى الجهه الشرقيه داخل
الغلاف من تل الزعتر جباليه التفاح
الشجاعيه هذه هي الاكثر تورطا وهي التي
ارسلت قبل 48 ساعه كتيبه مدرعات مدعومه
بكتيبه مشاء من لواء نحال مع سريه مدفعيه
ودخلت الى هذه المنطقه وتقاتل فيها كان
حديث عن الشيخ رضوان وعن الشاطئ القوات
التي توجد في الشمال هي التي دفعت بهذه
الجزئيات لماذا تدفع بهذه الجزئيات لان
هناك
حركه هناك حركه غير طبيعيه داخل المنطقه
تتمثل ب حركه مقاتلين مع طائرات كواد
كابتور ترسل معلومات وبالتالي يتم الارسال
الان اليه التعامل مختلفه عن المعركه
الاولى ه كيف اختلفت الان عندما تدخل هذه
القوات هي لا تدخل بصوره يعني خط عرضي
كامل انفتاح كامل لا تدخل بقوات استطلاع
مقد او حرس مقدمه هذه يتم التعامل معها
مجرد ان تدخل ضمن الاطار المدى من قبل
تم تصميم الدفاع تم تصميم الدفاع بان
يبعثوا عناصر استطلاع يعملوا بمقاربات
الذئاب المنفرده او الجماعات الصغيره يعني
الحد الاقصى ثلاث اشخاص معا شخصين معا او
شخص واحد يعملوا يؤدوا اكثر من دور عمليه
المراقبه والاستطلاع وجلب المعلومه وعمليه
ال النار والحركه لا يثبت في مكان يتنقل
من مكان لمكان واشرت قبل قليل وشاهدوا
حركات طيب هذا التغيير ما مرده هل مرده ان
هناك خسائر على الارض ام فعلا هذا كان ضمن
الاستراتيجيه من البدايه لا هو ضمن
استراتيجيه المقاومه وليس ضمن استراتيجيه
القوات الان تبدا الحركات يبدا هذ تندفع
القوات المعاديه يتم التعامل معها ضمن
مسافه جغرافيه بدايه التعامل كما قلت لك
بالعقد الصغيره او الخلايا الصغيره او
الذئاب المنفرده الان اليه التعامل تفضي
الى الاستدراج الاستدراج الى مناطق تقتيل
يكون قد تم تحضيرها مستقبلا هنا تبدا
المرحله الثانيه استخدام الحشوات والعبوات
والالغام وى غير ذلك اذا ما تمكن من
تجاوزها نتصل الى المرحله الثالثه وهي
مرحله المرحله التصادميه او معركه الصد
التي كنا نتحدث عنها سابقا وبالتالي الان
هذا معادله رابحه بالنسبه للمقاومه لان
المعادله المقا قابله ان تبقى هذه القوات
في الغلاف وتقوم باستمرار على مدار الساعه
بتنفيذ عمليات القصف سواء بالطائرات
العموديه الطائرات المسيره او بالقصف
المدفعي والصاروخي في هذه الحاله المقاومه
عليها ان تتلقى الضربات ولكن لا تستطيع ان
تقوم برد فعل لماذا لان رد الفعل بالنسبه
للمقاومه عليه محددات كبيره اهم هذه
المحددات المسافه الصفريه لا يستطيع ان
يقاتل لان مسافه صفر اذا علي ان اجلبه الى
مسافه الصفر حتى اقوم بدور رد الفعل هذه
في بصوره عامه ملخص المنطقه الشماليه يعني
اللافت ان الفيديوهات التي كنا نتابعها هل
لمست
تغيير في طريقه التصوير طريقه الاستهداف
الاهداف نفسها الان يعتمد حسب
المنطقه عندما تصدر الفيديوهات من مخي
مثلا منطقه التفاح والشجاع بالامس كان في
فيديو كان مختلفا عن الفيديوهات التي كنا
نشاهدها في نفس التفاح والشجاع بالامس لا
الاختلاف كان واضح خرج من النفق الى ارض
زراعيه اختار مكانا وسدد ورمى هذه الفرق
الاول بينما كنا نشاهد في الافلام القديمه
كان يخرج من بين الانقاذ وينفذ العمل من
داخل المبنى وسنشاهد الان معك وانت تشه
نعم هذه هذه هذه احد النقاط التي لاحظتها
النقطه الثانيه لا لاحظت روعه في التصوير
اكثر من اول بحيث تتبعت مسار المقذوف اذا
الان اذا الان هذا هو نفس الفيلم ونركز به
سنشاهد حركه
المقذوف لننتظر لحظه الان سيطلق بسم الله
الله
اكبر الم نشاهد المقذوف اثناء الحركه ها
هو اعم اذا هذه بعض الفروق الفرق الاول
الرئيسي اطلقه من ارض زراعيه بينما كنا
نتابعه من داخل
الباني لا الان خرج من فتحه النفق على سلم
حديدي من المواسير واختار هدفه الان هذه
مقاربه ثانيه هذا كان عمل مزدوج كان عمل
مزدوج وهذا شاهدنا مثله ان يقوم باطلاق
تاندم او الياسين 105 ويكون معه مساعده
فورا يبدا باستخدام لانه اذا لاحظتي كان
هناك سهم احمر عدد اثنين يؤشر على جنود
على مقربه من الهدف الرئيسي فتندم تعامل
مع الهدف الرئيسي فيما الجنود تعاملوا مع
الا طبعا هذه الفيديوهات تزعج اسرائيل
بشكل كبير وانت تتحدث عن فيديوهات تزداد
من حيث النوعيه يعني وضوحا
وتنظيما يعني الان هذه تعكس صوره مصغره هي
دعيني اقول هي لقطات هي لقطات تعبيريه عن
محتوى اكبر الان هذا احن نتحدث عن معارك
اذا ذهبنا الى الجنوب هذه صور مثلا سرايا
القدس ايضا يعني كنا ن الان سرايا القدس
قاموا باطلاق صواريخ ومن اين اطلقوها كما
وردت المعلومه من شرق مخيم
البريج مخيم البريج انا اتحدث يوجد لوائين
وتوجد الفرقه 99 اربع الوي لواء مدرع
وثلاث الوي مشاه كيف استطاع ان يخرج وان
ينقل هذه المهمات التي تبدو في ظاهرها
بدائيه ولاحظنا نوعين من الصواريخ 107
وبدر الان اذا اخذنا الان لاحظي هو الان
ماذا يركب
بالفيوز سنلاحظ بعد قليل مسمار التامين لم
لم ينزع لاحظي لم ينزع بعد هذه مسمار
التامين يقال له الان يفكه حتى يكون جاهز
الاطلاق هذه قاعده رباعيه بدائيه
و تم الاطلاق هذا الان الوزن المتفجرات 3
كيلوغرام المدى من 5 الى 8 كيلو متر الوزن
الاجمالي للصاروخ 18 كيلوغرام تقريبا وهذا
اللي هو تطوير عن صواريخ الكاتيوشا
107 تصنيع الهندسه العكسيه هذا اللي هو
كما يذكر اللي هو بدر واحد وهو ليس بدر
الذي في ايران او في عند الحوثي هذاك
صاروخ
بالستي لا هذا تطوير 107 اللي شاهدناه قبل
قليل تم زياده المدى الى 11 كيلو بدل 8
كيلو هذه ايضا نقطه مهمه يجب ان يعني
التفريق دائما لانه يمكن قد يتبادر للدهن
بدر هذه عند الحوثيين عندما نقول صاروخ
بدر واحد نتحدث عن صاروخ بالستي هذه تطوير
لكاتيوشا اللافت في مقابل فيديوهات
الكتائب وفيديو سرايا القدس كان هناك
فيديو جديد للجيش الاس اسرائيلي اليوم
استط استطيع التعليق عليه قبل ان اشاهده
كيف لانه الصوره مستنسخه عن ما كنا نشاهده
الان لنشاهد ها هو الان ال ونش
ال اليه الحفر
الهندسيه الان الجنود يتحركوا يطلقوا
النار على من لا اعلم الان يطلق النار على
الباب من مسافه الصفر على اساس انه يفتح
الباب بطريقه معينه حتى لا يكون انفجار
الان انا لا لا اشاهد اي طرف اخر يعني
اشاهد طرف واحد من
المعادله كالعاده وبالتالي قلت لك استطيع
الاجابه عن الاسئله قبل ان يشاهد
الفيلم
انظري يقوم بعمليات قص من اجل الانفاق
الجاري وبالامس ايضا الجيش كان بث فيديو
عن خان يونس تحديدا لماذا هذا التركيز على
خان يونس برايك خلال
جرى تحولات كثيره في منطقه غان يونس اول
المنطقه واسعه طبعا الناس واسعه مجازيا
عند العمق
12 العم 12 م مقابل 6 م وبالتالي صرنا
نتحدث عن مساحه واسعه كاننا نتحدث عن
سيبيريا ولا عن صحراء الصحراء الكبرى
نتحدث عن 362 م بس الكيلومتر له قيمته
واله مدلوله واله مستقبله
الان المنطقه الشرقيه جرى تح تعديلات
كثيره على الخطه القتاليه لكن اتوقف عند
اتوقف في في وقت قصير جدا عند المرحله
الاخيره منذ 48 ساعه هناك فتح ك مطر نتوقف
اصلا لان راس الساعه اشكرك جزيلا لواء
فايز دويري